Marvel might rule the cinema today but
before the MCU is king they release some
real stinkers animatronic ducks multiple
attempts at a Fantastic Four franchise
and Nicolas Cage and leather Marvel's
failures are legion these are the Marvel
movies that flopped at the box office
unlike most of the films on this list
blade Trinity actually did fairly well
at the box office
unfortunately the key word there is
fairly after the success of the first
two films in the saga Marvel's vampire
slaying daywalker blade Trinity's budget
was bumped up far beyond its
predecessors despite the extra cash in a
plot involving vampire dogs played
Trinity made almost exactly the same
amount as the first blade film did about
a hundred and thirty 1 million dollars
that was a huge profit for a surprise
hit made on a budget of seventeen
million but a little less than they
hoped for with Trinity's 65 million
dollar budget blade 2 also had a smaller
budget than blade Trinity but it made
about twenty million dollars more making
it clear that blade was daywalking
himself writing to some diminishing
returns
because the world is nice the
behind-the-scenes drama was ramping up
as well one particularly infamous story
involves star Wesley Snipes strangling
the film's director David s Goyer in
front of the crew and that's what's
going on behind the scenes it's no
wonder the producers started to think
that the Prophet Trinity brought in just
wasn't enough for the producers to deal
with the headache of making more blade
films blade is reportedly getting a
reboot into the MCU with more ursula
elise at the start let's hope he keeps
to the scripted violence and skips the
director strangling it's hard to imagine
what Marvel was thinking when they
decided that the first feature-length
film based on one of their comics should
be Howard the Duck to be fair Howard was
sort of the Deadpool of his day a comedy
oddball in the superhero universe that
frequently broke the fourth wall the
film which was jointly produced by
Lucasfilm and Marvel is generally
regarded as being a hot mess there's an
odd ickiness to the whole affair
starting with Howard's romance with
Beverly which asked audiences to be
totally cool with watching a duck hook
up with a very human lady
maybe Lea Thompson was trying to find
the one love scene that would be even
ski beour than the one she got when she
kissed Marty and back to the future
the plot is meandering the jokes never
quite land there's really no shortage of
reasons the film barely made back its
budget of 37 million dollars
interestingly Howard the Duck is
actually part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe already thanks to a couple of
cameos we wouldn't bet on another
starring role anytime soon though this
is another bomb that comes with an
asterisk
Ghost Rider spirit of vengeance the
second film starring what is arguably
the world's most famous on fire skeleton
that rides a motorcycle and punishes
sinners ultimately didn't do terribly at
the box office it wound up bringing in
132 million dollars against the 57
million dollar budget however a few red
flags went up with this one that landed
solidly in the flop category for one
thing spirit of vengeance made nearly a
hundred million dollars less than the
first Ghost Rider film that's a huge
drop-off especially considering the
films were released only a few years
apart secondly the domestic take in
particular went down significantly which
mattered a lot more in 2011 than it
might today one other factor is an
extremely technical element known to
filmmakers as Nicolas Cage
cage was one of the most marketable
movie stars around the late 1990s and
early 2000s but somewhere near 2010 the
backlash began as cage started taking
more questionable roles admittedly
starring in a supernatural superhero
movie directed by the two guys who made
the wildly fun over-the-top
prank films probably seemed like a safer
bet who knew the audiences would be the
ones wanting vengeance when this one
turned out to be so bad
The Incredible Hulk is considered one of
the few missteps Marvel made with their
phase 1 films Edward Norton seemed like
a slam-dunk pick as Bruce Banner and
you'll certainly find his vocal backers
around the internet especially in video
comment sections but Mark Ruffalo has
really taken the role of Hulk / banner
and made its own on paper The Incredible
Hulk is hardly a bomb and almost made
back its 150 million dollar budget and
ultimately brought in another 129
million dollars for a worldwide gross of
264 million dollars it does not however
come close to replicating the success of
Iron Man Robert Downey jr. first MCU
film blew audiences away and raked in
nearly six hundred million dollars and
that was with a smaller budget than the
Incredible Hulk it's not hard to see why
this one was a bit of a disappointment
for the brass in 2007 the trend of
big-budget superhero movies was just
starting to ramp up the x-men and
spider-man franchises had brought in
hundreds of millions of dollars and
Batman Begins proved that DC could
revive their biggest characters with a
popular critical hit - fans were also
gearing up for the following year which
would see the Dark Knight and a movie
star in one of Marvel's most enduring
fiy Lister's Iron Man that looked like
it might be fun Fantastic Four rise of
the Silver Surfer a sequel to the first
FF movie in 2005 that was adapting one
of the most groundbreaking and beloved
stories in comics history was in the
perfect spot to be a smash hit for
Marvel's first family all things
considered rise of the Silver Surfer
wasn't that bad when it came to
profitability the film at a massive 130
million dollar budget but ultimately
landed at a worldwide gross of 301
million dollars not bad until you see it
stacked up against other superhero
franchises like the spider-man films
which brought in over twice as much rise
of the Silver Surfer was definitely a
financial disappointment it didn't fare
better with fans either confronted with
the challenge of creating a big screen
tation of Galactus the planet jumping
devourer of worlds the filmmakers
decided to ditch the classic comic book
look and make him something much less
silly a cloud a really mean cloud after
this release it's no surprise that
Hollywood bigwigs decided that ffs just
couldn't hack it with the big voice and
put them back on the Shelf it would be
years before they would return for
another shot leading to the equally
disastrous 2015 Fantastic Four movie we
probably should have seen this one
coming though come on Chris Evans who
whatever buy that guy is a superhero
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you